( Intro ratée de Squeezie )
C'est la première vidéo dans le nouveau décoooooor !!!
Les amis, première vidéo dans ce nouveau décor
Et c'est l'occasion de tester un nouveau format
Un nouveau truc,
Euhh...
On va lire : des thread horreur
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? d'avoir tout changé pour faire la même chose qu'avant ?
Vous en pensez quoi ?
Mais on dirait que c'est nouveau du coup !
Comme rien n'a... n'est pareil qu'avant
Nan en vrai ça fait longtemps je suis méchant avec moi même
Ça fait à peu près un mois , j'crois qu'on n'a pas fait
De thread horreur
La dernière fois on était passé sur le "letsnotmeet" sur Reddit,
Et mon gars, il y a des histoires incroyables
En plus c'est vraiment des gens qui écrivent ce qu'ils ont vécu !
Aujourd'hui, laissez moi vous raconter 3 histoires...
vraiment horribles
Pour ceux qui ont vu la vidéo setup vous savez ce qu'il va se passer
C'est le moment de passer en mode thread horreur...
*musique angoissante et couleur sombre*
Ça marche biennnnnn !
La première histoire s'appelle :
"La femme de l’hôtel "
Michael et ces collègues
Étaient en déplacement pour le travail,
Et du coup dormaient dans un hôtel
Le soir.
Mais un jour en rentrant a l’hôtel , Michael
Il a eu une énorme surprise dans sa chambre
Lui et sa collègue , Rebecca , marchaient tranquillement dans le couloir de l’hôtel
Et Michael en ouvrant sa porte, il voit
Quelqu'un dans sa salle de bain
Alors premier reflex
On est dans un hôtel, généralement il peut y avoir
Quelqu'un dans ta chambre quand t'ouvres ta porte de chambre
Et c'est souvent quelqu'un qui fait le ménage
Sauf que :
Michael constate que ce que cette femme tient dans ces mains, c'est pas du linge qui traînait ou quoi que ce soit
C'est son sac à dos
Pourquoi quelqu'un qui vient pour faire le ménage aurait dans ses mains ton sac à dos dans ta salle de bain ?
Par réflexe il lui dit bonjour
Et la personne ne répond pas
Et fait comme si il n’était pas là
Michael se tourne alors vers sa collègue Rebecca
Qui était en train d'entrer dans sa chambre
Donc la chambre d’en-face de celle de Michael
Et lui dit " Rebecca il y a une femme dans ma chambre."
A partir de là, faut se dire que Michael est en état de choc, c'est à dire que il rentre chez lui
Comme il a fait plein de fois dans sa vie, dans sa chambre d’hôtel
Sauf que la il y a quelqu'un dans sa salle de bain
Et il est sur à 99% que ce n'est pas du tout quelqu'un pour faire le ménage
C'est quand même.... terrifiant comme situation
Il se retourne alors vers la femme qui est dans sa salle de bain
Et il lui dit:
"Qu'est ce que vous faites avec mes affaires dans vos mains?"
La femme laisse tomber son sac-à-dos,
Et sort de la chambre avec son sac à mains à elle dans la main
Et un sac en plastique.
Et Michael, lui, il reprend un peu ses esprits
Et il lui dit:
"Y'a quoi dans le sac en plastique?"
Elle ouvre le sac et montre à Michaël,
Et effectivement, aucune affaire à Michaël dans le sac
Mais que celles de la femme.
Michaël, toujours en état de choc, laisse partir la femme de la chambre.
Et il est complètement sur le cul, il comprend rien à ce qui vient de lui arriver
Normal!
Michael rentre dans sa chambre,
Il check à gauche, à droite, voir s'il y a des affaires à lui qui ont été volées
Très bon réflexe.
Et bizarrement, tout est là:
Son PC, son portable,...
Tous ses appareils électroniques, les trucs qui sont petits et qui valent cher,
Sont toujours en place et ils ont pas été pris par la femme.
Il va alors ensuite, dans sa salle de bains, voir si il manque des choses
Parce que c'est là qu'était la femme au moment où il l'a pris en flagrant délit.
Problème, Michael a un traitement
Contre je sais plus quelle maladie, bref,
Il y a des médicaments qu'il doit prendre tous les jours
Et ils étaient dans sa salle de bains, et ils ne sont plus là
Elle les a volés.
Michael court alors vers la sortie de la chambre,
Pour rattraper la dame.
Elle est pas dans le couloir,
Il fait le tour de l'hôtel, il va à la buanderie,
Il check le haul d'accueil,
Il check partout.
Plus aucune trace de cette mystérieuse femme.
Il se rend alors, avec Rebecca, à l'accueil
Pour témoigner de c'qui vient de se passer
Pt pour appeler les flics, pour dire" voilà y'avait un intrus dans ma chambre
Quelqu'un a essayé de me voler
Euh...
Retrouvez-le, y'a un blème" !
En attendant que la police arrive, il retourne dans sa chambre avec Rebecca,
Pour continuer sa petite enquête à lui
Et voir s'il lui manque des affaires ou pas.
Etil remarque qu'il y a sur son lit une batte de baseball en métal
et il y a une lampe de poche accrochée à l'extremité de la batte
Quel est cet accessoire étrange ?
Pourquoi un combo si bizarre ?
A part peut-être taper des gens dans l'obscurité
Rien de rassurant en tout cas ! Rien du tout de rassurant.
Peu de temps après, la police arrive sur les lieux
Ils se rendent dans la chambre de Michael
Et ils prennent sa déclaration, et celle aussi de Rebecca, qui a été témoin de tout ça
Michael remarque alors un truc très étrange,
C'est que dans le l'évier de sa salle de bain, il y'a des morceaux de cloison sèche
Peut-être que c'est des morceaux du plafond qui sont tombés
Parce que l'hôtel est un peu vieux mais bon au plafond, il n'a pas de traces d'usures donc a priori c'est pas ça
Les policiers et Mickaël vont plutôt essayer de trouver le chemain par lequel elle est arrivée dans la chambre
Est-ce que c'est une fenêtre qui a été cassée?
Est-ce que c'est une porte qui a été enfoncée?
Est-ce qu'elle était cachée sous le lit sans qu'il s'en rende compte, depuis un moment?
Et ben que dalle.
La porte est dans un état nickel, les fenêtres pareils.
On n'sait pas comment elle est arrivée là
Ils vont alors demander à l'accueil de l'hôtel
Si c'est pas possible qu'elle ait trouvé ou gardé une carte plus vieille de la chambre
Et que la carte marche toujours parce que l'hôtel a oublié de la désactiver ou un truc à la con comme ça.
L'hôtel est formel: "Non, c'est impossible".
L'officier présent sur les lieux va appeller deux autres officiers en renfort
Pour essayer de retrouver la femme
Peut-être qu'elle est encore dans les parrages
Mais ça donne rien, que dalle
Donc ils ont juste pris la déclaration de Mickaël et ils sont partis
Mickaël va alors se poser sur son lit et passer des coups de fils, euh, pour raconter ce qu'il s'est passé
Il vient de vivre un truc très choquant
Et il repense à cette histoire de morceaux de cloisons sèches dans l'évier et il se dit: "Putain mais il y a un truc qui ne va pas avec ça c'est bizarre"
Il a le flair, il a le flair
Il est meilleur inspecteur que nous. N'ayez pas le seum.
Il retourne dans la salle de bain, regarde les morceaux de cloisons sèches, lève la tête, regarde le miroir qui est en face de lui
Et d'un coup... BOUM ! Euréka !
Il décroche le miroir du mur et derrière le miroir se trouve un trou
Voilà, c'est la photo, la seule photo qu'il y a dans le thread de Mickaël
C'est celle-là
Et mon gars, ça fait froid dans le dos
Le trou, il fait pile la taille pour que quelqu'un s'y glisse, quoi.
Les policiers étaient encore sur le parking de l'hôtel.
Mickaël, il va les chercher, il leur dit: "Écoutez, je crois que je viens de trouver un bail, là, c'est indescent, venez voir vite"
Les policiers montent. Ils inspectent dans le trou et ils y trouvent un oreiller, des couvertures, des cigarettes, des vêtements, une brosse à dent
La mystérieuse femme que Mickaël avait vu dans sa salle de bain vivait en fait de l'autre côté du mur, dans ce putain de trou
Il y avait en fait un espace entre le mur de la salle de bain de Mickaël et le mur de la chambre voisine
Un espace que Mickaël décrit comme faisant deux pieds et donc un espace d'environ 60 cm
Donc pas très large mais suffisant pour que quelqu'un s'y glisse et dorme là
Et ait accès à une chambre d'hôtel quand la personne qui a loué la chambre d'hôtel n'est pas dans la chambre d'hôtel
Mickaël explique ensuite ce qui est ouf c'est que ça devait faire un bon moment qu'elle était là parce qu'il avait déjà été en déplacement à cet endroit, là.
Et il avait déjà dormi dans cette chambre d'hôtel plusieurs mois avant
Et il avait senti une odeur de cigarette dans sa chambre mais il avait pensé comme tout le monde que c'était peut-être dans une autre chambre que quelqu'un fumait dans la salle de bain
Et que la fumée était arrivé dans sa salle de bain à lui par les aérations, vous savez tout est un peu relié
Mais non mec, il y a juste une meuf qui fumait de l'autre côté de ton miroir, dans ton mur, tranquille
Et quand tu partais, elle sortait du mur et elle allait faire une petite sieste dans ton lit à toi, bien plus confortable que le sien
Et elle prenait les choses dans ton mini bar, peut-être même qui sait ?
Mec, c'est horrible
C'est tellement badant
En fait ce qui est horrible c'est de se dire "putain, il y a quelqu'un qui était là depuis tout ce temps, tout près de moi, vraiment dans mon espace intime et j'ai rien vu"
Hop, la!!
Pleins de gens qui auront peur de dormir à l'hôtel, prochainement, moi y compris
Bon, il est temps de passer à la deuxième histoire qui était toute aussi badante même plus badante encore
Je trouve c'est la pire situation
Mais elle est différente, c'est pas la même mécanique. Ah on varie !
Laissez-moi vous raconter l'histoire de Lucie et Maxime
qui étaient au supermarché avec leur enfant, et tout est parti en couilles.
Tout a commencé par le bébé qui commençait à s'agiter,
à crier dans tous les sens,
à pleurer, pour le plus grand plaisir des gens qui font leurs courses
Nan en vrai le pire c'est dans un avion, en vrai au supermarché on s'en fout
Dans l'avion c'est un peu dur... Mais on a tous été comme ça,
Alors on peut rien y faire... C'est faux !
C'est faux. Jetez-les par la... le hublot
*rires* C'est horrible c'que j'dis !
Tout a commencé par un... un petit caprice du bébé
Bon vous savez c'est un bébé, il a ses petites phases
Et donc Maxime, le père, l'a pris et l'a amené sur le parking pour pas déranger les gens qui faisaient leurs courses
Oh Maxime il respecte bien les gens, lui l'individualisme il connait pas lui
C'est le monsieur parfait !
Moi le bébé pleure, je regarde les autres, je leur dis "CHEH"
C'est ce qui t'attend quand t'auras un enfant... "CHEH"
Après j'ai une mentalité de merde !
Maxime l'amène donc dans sa voiture sur le parking pour lui faire faire un petit tour
C'est ce qui endort beaucoup les bébés, moi même j'crois quand j'étais petit ma mère faisait ça pour m'endormir, voilà.
Il en avait que pour 10mn donc Lucie est restée dans le magasin
...Et a continué de faire les courses
Mais elle voyait ce qui se passait sur le parking.
Mais alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur le parking?
Très badant
Une femme marche vers Maxime, qui se tient bien droite, dans la trentaine, taille moyenne, bref !
Rien d'affolant en apparence, tout l'inverse!
Elle te met complètement en confiance
Précision importante, Lucie qui raconte l'histoire nous indique que c'est pas rare...
...Que des gens viennent les voir pour poser des questions sur le bébé, jouer avec leur bébé, etc.
Ce qui explique pourquoi Maxime n'a pas réagi en mode affolé, tout de suite.
Les siestes de ce bébé étant très importantes...
Maxime s'apprête à dire à la femme, que "Non, ça ne va pas être possible de jouer avec lui."
Mais la femme s'approche avec une démarche déterminée
Et avant même qu'il puisse terminer sa phrase,
La femme prend le porte-bébé dans lequel se trouve le bébé, et s'en va....
What ??
Maxime reste sous le choc
Il lui faut quelques secondes pour réaliser ce qu'il se passe
"Est ce que quelqu'un vient vraiment, en plein jour, de prendre mon bébé ??"
Au calme !
Il dit alors à la femme de poser le porte-bébé, avant de se mettre un peu à paniquer, quand même ça fait un peu peur...
Mais la femme reste calme, et continue de s'éloigner...
Maxime se met alors un peu à hausser le ton
À lui dire d'arrêter tout de suite, de poser le porte-bébé.
Et à mesure qu'il se met à parler de plus en plus fort, elle se met à marcher de plus en plus vite !
Il se décide alors à taper un gros sprint pour la rattraper
Sauf que le porte-bébé étant devant elle, il est juste à porter de ses bras, donc il lui attrape le bras
Et là, le pire moment de sa vie...
La meuf se met à crier et elle dit :
" Aidez moi s'il vous plait, ce mec essaye de voler mon bébé, appelez le 911 ! "
NON !
Elle lui met un coup dans le tibia, et elle sort une gazeuse de son sac à main
Le réflexe vraiment comme si une femme étant agressée pour de vrai
Et qu'elle cherchait à se défendre
Sauf que là, c'est elle la kidnappeuse, et lui il a rien fait, c'est son bébé, c'est horrible !
Tous les gens du parking, n'ayant pas vu ce qu'il s'est passé avant,
Ils se retournent et voient une femme avec une gazeuse dans la main,
Qui est bien habillée, qui est propre sur elle, qui a un porte bébé,
Et à côté de ça, ils voient un mec qui a un tee-shirt DeadPool
C'est Lucie qui le dit, c'est pas moi !
N'ayant pas le contexte et vu l'urgence de la situation,
Ils se jettent sur Mickael et ils le mettent à terre
C'est pas le truc le plus injuste et horrible...?
C'est pas toi le méchant de l'histoire, et tout le monde croit que c'est toi...
C'est horrible....
Les gens conseillent à la femme qui a volé le bébé d'aller porter plainte, de pas laisser Mickael sans punition...
Et la femme sort son meilleur jeu d'acteur, elle joue celle qui est bouleversée, qui réalise pas ce qu'il vient de lui arriver
Et elle dit "Non non, je veux juste rentrer chez moi et oublier ça, je veux juste rentrer chez moi, laissez moi, merci "
Mickael la voit alors ouvrir la porte de son mini Van
La voiture la moins rassurante du monde...
Finalement la voiture complètement cliché du kidnappeur d'enfant, vraiment...
C'est celle là !
Et les gens continuent, en attendant la police, de maintenir Mickael au sol
Bloqué comme ça, il peut pas bouger
Il voit son bébé partir au loin avec cette femme
Et il peut rien faire à part crier et dire que c'est lui le père, et que c'est son bébé
...Sauf que personne le croit.
Voyant Mickaël s'agiter, l'un des hommes qui le tient lui mais deux énormes coups de pieds dans les côtes.
Et ça va feller 2 côtes à Mickaël
Qui est entrain de se faire voler son bébé
Se retrouve en plus avec des côtes pétées, c'est cool, nickel
En sortant du magasin, Lucie, elle tombe sur son mari qui est maintenu au sol par plusieurs personnes
Et elle croit d'abord qu'il est entrain en fait de se faire raquetter
Elle se met alors à hurler sur les gens
À leur dire de lâcher et en tournant la tête, elle voit une femme qui tient son porte-bébé
Sauf qu'elle va croire que la femme a en faite sortit le bébé du danger pour pas qu'il lui arrive quoi qu'ce soit lors du raquettage de Mickaël
Le qui pro quo de l'enfer
Lucie ne trouve pas le gars qui gère la sécurité à la sortie du magasin
Alors elle se précipite vers les gens qui sont sur Mickaël
Et elle leur dit: "Prenez mon porte-feuille, prenez tous ce que vous voulez mais laissez-le en-dehors de ça, fouttez-lui la paix
Et là, l'un des mecs qui tient Mickaël lui dit: "Madame, on doit le maintenir le temps que la police arrive."
Lucie se dit "alors pourquoi les mecs qui rackettent mon mari auraient appelés la police?" Frère aucun sens.
Elle leur demande alors, elle leur dit: "Mais pourquoi, pourquoi la police? Qu'est-ce qu'il a fait exactement? Je ne comprends pas."
Et les mecs qui tiennent Mickaël au sol lui répondent: " Il a essayé de kidnapper euh le bébé de cette femme."
Et d'un coup, elle comprend, elle comprend que son mari s'est fait volé le bébé et qu'en voulant arrêté la femme, les gens ont pris lui pour le kidnappeur
Elle se met à chercher autour, la femme qu'elle avait vu juste avant qui portait le porte-bébé
Et elle l'apperçoit de l'autre côté du parking
Elle tape son meilleur sprint vers elle
Elle lui tire hyper fort les cheveux à tel point que la femme laisse tomber le porte-bébé
Et elle se jette sur le porte-bébé pour le recouvrir et que plus personne ne puisses toucher à son bébé
La femme est alors monté dans son mini-van, elle est partit et personne n'a essayer de l'arrêter
Personne
L'injustice de toute cette situation, le qui pro quo de toute cette situation est absolument horrible
Tout est horrible
C'est fou ça montre vraiment que quand on voit une scène mais que l'on a pas le contexte que l'on a pas ce qui c'est passé avant on peut complètement se trompé sur la situation, c'est vraiment horrible
Et à cause de ce truc là, ce couple-là, ce jour-là a failli se faire kidnapper leur bébé, quand même, c'est ouf
Ils ont vécu un truc parfaitement injuste et horrible et bon il s'en sont remis depuis mais c'était très traumatisant
Ils expliquent, Lucie explique ensuite, qu'il sont rentrés chez eux et qu'ils ont juste pleurer pendant des heures avant d'aller chercher leurs trois autres enfants à l'école et de faire comme si de rien de tout cela n'est arrivé
Voilà
Moral de l'histoire, il y a pas de moral
Un truc de merde peut toujours te tomber dessus
C'est le pur hasard
Et il faut juste savoir agir pour te sortir de cette merde
Et voilà, bref. Pleins de bisous à Lucie et Mickaël qui ont vécus un enfer même s'ils ne sont pas du tout français et qu'ils ne verront jamais cette video
Bref. Troisìème et dernière histoire qui est bien plus courte, mais très badante !
Alexandre explique, qu'il vit dans un quartier assez
Difficile. Qui vit avec 4 collocs, mais
Que, cette histoire s'est passée pendant les fêtes de Noël.
Et donc, il était seul chez lui.
Il a reçut pour noël une sonnette qui contient une caméra,
Et en fait quand quelqu'un sonne, tu reçois une notification et tu peux
Voir du coup, qui a sonner  grâce à la camera qui a dans la sonnette.
Alexandre, l'a donc attaché sur l'encadrement d'sa porte,
Les jours passent, le facteur sonne pour livrer un colis...
Il reçoit la pt'ite notif, il voit la tête du facteur, il est content
Tout  marches à merveille, tout ce passent bien.
Sauf qu'un jour, il rentre du travail,  et la sonnette, n'est, plus là.
Ont lui a voler !
Il est un peu dègue, mais d'un autre coté il n'est pas surpris
Il s'dit , bah oui c'est évident que un objet cool comme ça, juste scotcher à ma parois, bah...
Si un mec qui veut le voler, il peut TRÈS facilement l'faire.
Il explique où au moment qu'il raconte cette histoire,  que la veille au soir
Quelqu’un a sonné sur cette fameuse sonnette.
Même si j'le rappelle, elle n'est plus devant sa porte
Elle est toujours connectée à son téléphone, il ouvre l'application,
Et là, la vidéo lui apparaît et c'est ça maison.
Le mec, qui avait volé la sonnette, était là, juste devant la maison d'Alex.
Et filmait la maison d'Alex avec la sonnette.
Tout va bien.
Alex panique un peut, surtout qu'il explique  que c'est un quartier ou il s'passe
pas mal de trucs, euh... Pas cool. Que lui même il s'est fait voler, agresser une fois.
Et d'un coup l'image de l'application redevient noir, comme si le voleur de la sonnette venait de la remettre dans sa poche.
Alex se précipite vers sa fenêtre, pour voir si il y a quelqu’un devant chez lui.
Sauf que personne n'était là !
Le mec a probablement eu le temps de se barrer.
Mais juste, c'est horrible !
Un mec te vole ton truc.
Et des jours plus tard, il film ton chez toi.
Avec ce truc.
C'est pas le début d'un film d'horreur !  C'est horrible !
N'achetez pas d'sonneeetes ! C'est bien ! Toquez regardez.
Regardez ça marche bien !
*Toc-Toc-Toc*
Oui, y'a quelqu’un ?!?!
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo thread.
Du coup, p, peux prepasser sur des belles, belles lumières,
Lumineuuuse !!! Voilà !!!
Vous savez quoi ? Je commencer à me chier dessus
Parce que l'à, mine de rien, il est 20h passer...
J'ai mis toutes mes lampes connectés en rouge. Je suis dans le noir.
J'me chie un peut de dessus. *rire*
J’espère que ces 3 histoires vous ont plus.
J'essaie comme d'habitude à chaque fois de trouver des mécaniques diffamantes.
Que ça soit pas toujours la même mécanique qui fait peur.
Ne vous en faite pas, vous n'avez pas besoin de vérifier derrière le miroir.
Vous pouvez aller dans une chambre d’hôtel. J'vous jure, y'aura pas troue, y'aura pas de personne dans vos murs.
Sauf si vous tomber dans la chambre d’hôtel que ce mec avait loué. *rires*
Je ne dirais pas quel hôtel c'est ! Ni où il est ! C'est le hasard !
C'est fou je le répète, mais c'est fou comme là, il ne s'agit pas de truc paranormal. De fantômes ou quoi.
C'est juste des gens qui sont félés quoi.
Et ça peux tellement nous tomber tous dessus. C'est super Badant !
Je vous dit bisous à tous et dans une prochaine vidéo.
C'est bon, vous allez mal dormir pendant 1 semaine.
Puis ensuite, y'aura 3 semaines où vous allez bien faire dodo.
Avant la prochaine vidéo des Thread d'horreur !
Je vous laisse !
Sur une obscurité avec une touche de rouge.
Et bonne nuit, hein ! Allez ! Chao !
*MUSIC* Note des sous-titreurs : ça change vraiment pour excellentes vidéos !